[Música]
eu sou realmente uma mãe que acha da
matemática é algo que eu gosto e é uma
área a qual eu me dedico às vezes quando
eu vou a antártica um amigo do meu pai
eu conhecem muito bem
andamento perguntou sempre a então itu
em que a next tas e expondo no segundo
eu sim
no segundo eu sim apesar de ter a
aparência de uma batata com 12 anos eu
já estou na faculdade
no segundo ano do curso de matemática e
vocês andor por ar que em qualquer
circunstância social quando surge a
palavra matemática assim por aquela
pessoa que dirige um huey ii matemática
em que se vê nada visto nas escolas que
não gostou do taboado certa suruí isso e
outras e não apreciando epa também eu
ainda bem que já não está em lei com
isso e o espírito é o nome engraçado no
meio em que nós vivemos é completamente
aceitável quase que é difícil alguém não
saber matemática mas por exemplo não
saber ler ou escrever é completamente
impensável e vocês podem ser a unhas mas
faz algum sentido
nós precisamos sabendo ele escrever no
nosso dia a dia é fundamental mas não
quiseram saber uma pitada sobre equações
diferenciais segundo grau
sim vocês têm toda a razão pois não eu
até me ajoelho porta voz sempre ficar
sem sabedoria mas eu continuo sem
perceber e é esse argumento de que não
precisa aprender isso porque não vou
utilizar tempo as taxas que nós só temos
a aprender aquilo que é absolutamente
necessário para a nossa sobrevivência e
ficar por aí
tipo tu usas severas em casa ou como
suas mãos por não é totalmente
necessário utilizar uma faca e um garfo
é uma coisa que o senhor não consegue
entender e para o início a uma crença é
quem é muito comum que é nós acharmos
que matemática é só para alguns ou se
acha que o jeito é uma forma de marcar
então esquece a forte e
sim eu não li nenhum isto buddha nenhum
psicólogo norte-americano sobre o
assunto mas eu quero pelo menos a
acreditar que isso não é verdade
a rais que corre sem pernas e bem fingem
rio portanto porque eu fiquei pessoas no
ano consegui aprender matemática
tudo bem tudo bem eu sei que também a
produzi ativos que vivem o campeonato de
xadrez com cinco anos e é normal que as
pessoas com mais facilidade em obter
certos conceitos ou conduzir racine
forma mais clara mas isso não quer dizer
nasa eu acho que todos nós conseguimos a
quer dizer haver um grupo de pessoas que
realmente têm uma predisposição maior
mais algum talento mas acreditem
primeiro eu não tou incluída nesse grupo
pessoas ao cair a eu não sou assim no
jardim caiu do céu
há portanto é apesar de eu não ser
excecional nem ai eu tenho vindo a fazer
progressos e aquilo que eu conseguir foi
de vida trabalho e não há talento pois
deixem se de tretas vencerá não tem
jeito a matemática tem escala vai
trabalhar pronto alguém
posto isto é assim eu só queria deixar
bem claro que não espera que toda a
gente gosta de matemática não acho que
toda a gente dizia vou aprender
matemática e muito - considero que quem
sabe matemática de alguma forma superior
às outras pessoas não é nada disso
o que eu acho é que nós em em sociedade
podemos valorizar mais o conhecimento e
aprendizagem e melhor porque sabemos
coisas é desenvolvermos a nossa
capacidade de fazer o iene estava com a
minha cara a sua primeira no valor do
conhecimento a gente passa com as botas
luvas 12 anos de história na escola e
isso não conta mas a questão conta esse
na minha opinião a escola as muitas
presenças certas linhas roubar os átomos
nós nos ensina realmente a buscar
automática nós falamos de mim essas
fórmulas e diria mais
infecções mas falta algo falta novamente
por mês os alunos a pensar a fazer
matemática pensar para os próprios
porque só assim é que nós vamos aprender
não é números a fórmula está bem e eu
quero agora que vocês e tentei nesta
situação vai ficar aqui nunca tem lei
enxergou está na hora de o usuário uma
vez na mira favor a alguém então temos
aqui um quadriculado o terroir como
queiram que é 10 por 10 portanto temos
de responder com os resultados as coisas
não ficam sem no top e nós nesse
tabuleiro podemos por peças que são
quatro por um ou seja cada peça ocupa
quatro casos do goleiro
vocês podem bolos como quiserem livre
arbítrio meus amigos podem boas assim no
entanto tal não fique calmo pois assim
pois assim descarta uma pronto fica
assim nas casas de banho a e agora tem
uma questão para vocês
será que é possível cobrir o do leitor
com estas peças sem que haja sobre
posições ou seja pegar nas peças já
vamos a 25 25 a 14
será que nós conseguimos preencher do
informa que não haja buracos mas também
não fiquem peças em cima de outras toda
a gente perceber ainda marcava 0 a
zonagem estatística quem é que acha que
é possível porém o braço no ar
não tenham vergonha te vou ok ainda
temos alguns clientes pra você esquece
que é possível sim por ser uma pergunta
que comece por é possível não sei que a
resposta e com a sempre não é fato am
resposta também é não mas nós vamos
provar porque marquei nós fazemos que
nós achamos que alguma coisa de uma
certa forma nós temos duas demonstrar
através de um certo fascínio não é dizer
olha eu acho que é assim porque sim
vocês não terá pontuação no teste que
fazer isso então vou tentar arranjar um
argumento para provar isto é isto stone
se por ser um caso complicado porque
vocês olham pra lá e por um lado isso
não parece ser
vida através de uma fórmula a linha
semana uma forma que aprenderam que sou
visto valor não e prometem disso as não
se vocês tivessem um tablet mesmo
fisicamente as peças a primeira coisa
que vocês vão fazer provavelmente vai
começar a experimentar o primeiro uma na
horizontal e vertical e horizontal
resultado ao ficar lotado mas vocês não
iam sítios é ensinar o número
configurações possíveis tanto quanto
falha quando vocês não sabem nem uma
fórmula que usou uma coisa ou então não
têm tempo suficiente ou paciência para
fazer o espaço todos mecanicamente por
si sendo ocorrer a ferramenta mais
importante que já foi aqui me assinada
que cria dívida criatividade ea mãe
trabalhar aquilo calaça e eu acho que
vai estar o hertha 5543 individual e
desta forma nas filas nas linhas
em parte eu pus amarelo sul nelson
mandela usou nas outras bolsas por meio
de verba e verde vermelho e expulsou o
problema em causa é que nós podemos
fazer para que sempre que nós fomos uma
peça ela ocupa duas casas amarelas e dos
vasos ou blusa azul e 2 verde ou seja
cada peça ocupa duas casas todos uma
certa cor dos casos ajudamos a mesma
força e tu tá fazendo olha e mas há um
pequeno problema é que essa em cada peça
cobra um número par dos céus de cada cor
mas o nosso tamanho da forma que foi
pintado tem 25 peças de cada cor
ou seja tem uma quantidade em parte
peças de cada cor
as nossas peças jogou bem o número 40
então é impossível que elas consigam
cobrir um número ímpar sempre ter a
mesma qualidade que servem manhã em
piscina curta foi sempre nos vídeos e
não gostou domingo e torcer muito gosta
de poder dizer
obrigado a jogar bem e hoje que obama é
fantástico vocês ficaram não tem a mesma
opinião mas pronta a nos fornecer feito
a equipe porque gosta do flamengo
santíssimo
porque você explorar em assunção deixou
literalmente pintar o goleiro e agora
perguntamos quem raio é que havia de ter
esta ideia é mesmo de ser criativos é um
problema de matemática que literalmente
gorro ao pintar um funk em do goleiro
é incrível a ira das coisas que fosse
não é porque eu estava de marca porque é
um desafio porque isso aqui queira nossa
criatividade cristo é matemática acre
tempo mas vocês iam ver isto num livro
matemática porque não é imediatamente
resolvido criando aquela fórmula que
aparece na página 73 então é proibido
normal mantega está na escola não pode
ser criativo como o dia 20
a e.on e seriedade que mais pessoas
podiam estar matemática e apreciar a sua
beleza se enganassem forma diferente
sobretudo se ela fosse ensinada a de uma
forma diferente
a matemática é uma linguagem outro
sistema para transmitir idéias é é a
arte de pensar com clareza a muito
passear mas pronto da forma como as
coisas estão a maior parte dos alunos
atualmente não estabelece uma ligação
com a matemática para eles é só mais uma
tribuna chata e inútil que o que tem de
fazer e por isso é que muitas vezes
vocês podem ouvir colegas a dizer
a professora o que elas querem que eu
faça neste exercício a eles querem que
eu multiplica o que queriam os querem
como se houvesse um conselho dos meus
matemáticos e se vocês não fizerem um
exercício com wells querem levantar um
raio na cabeça onde a trupe regra 1 265
fora é público não fazer piadas na toca
os brothers ah e eu comecei a fazer
essas observações sobre a forma como a
matemática é ensinada que nós pensamos
nela depois de participar nas olimpíadas
de matemática são a competição em diante
e nós realmente temos de batalhar contra
os problemas e e ter idéias fora de casa
ah não não é uma função técnica de
exercícios como na escola portanto a eu
tenho muitas máquinas depois eu chegava
às aulas e pronta a depositar matemática
não era a mesma coisa votar em qualquer
coisa e eu tive professores e estudantes
a culpa não é dos professores ou pelo
menos não é só dos professores às salas
de professores só presta
depois de vocês limpar empurrava o papel
higiênico nos querem voltar a limpar o
mato e então eu como sempre nunca entre
nas ruas muito maior que o de preços
menores nas crianças
de qualquer modo por eu não estar aqui a
reclamar sem fazer nada porque por acaso
não gosto muito reclamar coisas é um
assunto para o lado positivo mas algumas
coisas pra gente só quer dizer que eu
acho que a equação matemática pode ser
pior que todos nós temos um potencial
para descobrir podemos apreciar a
matemática é por ajudar linhas objetivo
é e há dois anos ajudou a mãe a 1 o
canal de matemática em ter autorizado
este ano de matemática outras histórias
os matemáticos malucos ou os desafios
são mais curtos e o objetivo é mesmo
fazer com pessoas encarem a matemática
com uma perspectiva diferente mais
humorístico é mais pronunciada e
portanto é isso que eu também faço nos
meus tempos livres e eu eu espero que
daqui a uns tempos as aulas de
matemática passem de algo como a soma
dos quadrados que o teto é igual ao
quadrado enquanto usa
oremos irmãos
por algum caminho mais picada e eu tenho
essa esperança mas entretanto que as
coisas não mudam e modelar pensamos
irmãos muita briga
[Aplausos]